This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The ocean is not our place. We can't breathe under there, we can't really see, we can learn to swim, but it doesn't come naturally. Apes don't swim. They want nothing to do with putting their bodies into water. It's only human kinds incessant need to explore that drives us into such an unwelcoming environment. And since our bodies aren't built for it, we must design things that allow us to explore this foreign place. And we have. That's our own Katie Mangle. Alexander the Great is said to have descended into the ocean more than 2,000 years ago in a
这里是“99%隐形”栏目。我是罗曼·马斯。海洋不属于我们。我们在那里无法呼吸，也看不真切；我们可以学会游泳，但这并非天生。类人猿不会游泳。它们压根不想把身体泡进水里。正是人类探索未知的不羁天性，驱使我们进入这样一个充满敌意的环境。既然我们的身体并非为此而生，我们就必须设计出能让我们探索这个陌生地方的工具。而我们也确实做到了。那是我们自己的凯蒂·曼格尔。据说亚历山大大帝在两千多年前就曾坐着一个
glass barrel. There are various paintings of this event. In one, the great is being lowered into the ocean by a couple of men in a wooden boat. He's hunched inside his little barrel, still wearing his crown and robe. The guys in the boat look to me like they are used to humoring his every whim. In some versions of the story, Alexander the Great was not in a barrel, but in a diving bell. Diving bells have been around for a long time. Aristotle wrote about them around 300 BC. And they were often actual bells, like from churches.
玻璃桶潜入过海底。有许多关于这一事件的画作。其中一幅画中，这位伟人正被几个坐在木船里的人放入海中。他蜷缩在小小的木桶里，依然戴着王冠、穿着长袍。在我看来，船上的那些家伙似乎对他的每一个异想天开都习以为常、顺其自然。在该故事的一些版本中，亚历山大大帝不是坐在桶里，而是坐在潜水钟里。潜水钟已经存在很长时间了。亚里士多德在公元前300年左右就曾撰文提及它们。而且它们通常就是真正的钟，比如教堂里的那种。
To understand how one uses such a thing to aid in an ocean dive, try this quick experiment. Fill up your sink with water and push a cup open and down into the water. You'll notice that the cup doesn't fill up all the way. There will be a pocket of breathable air on the inside. Amazingly, this works using giant church bells and the ocean too. Divers could lower a belt into the ocean and use it as a kind of home base, swimming out and around, searching for sunken treasure, and then popping back into the bell
为了解人们如何利用这种装置辅助深海下潜，你可以做一个简单的实验。把水槽装满水，将一个杯子杯口朝下压入水中。你会发现杯子并没有完全进水。里面会留有一个充满可呼吸空气的气泡。神奇的是，这种原理对巨大的教堂钟和海洋同样适用。潜水员可以将一个大钟沉入海中，把它当作某种大本营，游进游出，搜寻沉没的宝藏，然后再次钻回钟里
for a few gasps of air. But it wasn't a good solution. The air didn't last long. The bells were cumbersome, and the divers still couldn't go down very far because of the pressure. The main obstacle to exploring the depths of the ocean has always been the pressure. Well, at 200 feet, your lungs collapse and you die. That's Jim Gould telling it like it is.
大口喘几口气。但这不是一个长久之计。空气维持不了多久。潜水钟十分笨重，而且由于水压限制，潜水员仍然无法潜到太深的地方。探索深海的最大障碍一直都是水压。嗯，在200英尺（约61米）深处，你的肺就会塌陷，然后你就会死亡。这是吉姆·古尔德在实话实说。
I'm Jim Gould. I'm a professor of biology at Princeton. And he's married to Carol Gold, who will also be talking to you today. I'm Carol Gold. I'm a science writer. She and Jim have written ten books together. They've been married for 45 years. This is how Jim talks about the first time he met Carol. And there she was, the person I've been looking for all my life. And it didn't take long from then.
我是吉姆·古尔德。我是普林斯顿大学的生物学教授。他和卡罗尔·古尔德结了婚，卡罗尔今天也会和大家交谈。我是卡罗尔·古尔德。我是一名科普作家。她和吉姆合著了十本书。他们已经结婚45 years。吉姆是这样描述他第一次见到卡罗尔时的情景的。当时她就在那里，那正是我一生都在寻找的人。从那以后没过多久，
It's true. It's very sweet. Again. Backed to oceans. In the mid-1800s, a natural is named Edward Forbes, hypothesized that below 300 fathoms or about 1800 feet no life could exist in the ocean and people pretty much believed him. Well the general thought was that it was just common sense that nothing could live down there
千真万确。非常甜蜜。言归正传，让我们回到海洋。19世纪中叶，一位名叫爱德华·福布斯的博物学家提出假设：在300英里寻（约2740米）以下，或者说大约1800英尺（约549米）以下的海洋中不可能存在任何生命，人们基本上都相信了他的说法。当时普遍的看法是，常识告诉我们那种地方不可能有生物存活，
because the deeper you get the pressure increases on the living tissues and it gets darker and darker and it just made sense to people, you know, the way we are. So anthropocentric, if people can't live down there well, probably nothing else can. But these anthropocentric naysayers would soon be proven wrong. The continents were about to be strung together with telegraph wires. Starting in 1858, nations were connected with extremely long wires. Messages would travel great distances through cables that lay on the ocean floor. And in 1860, as the Mediterranean cable was raised for repair from about 6,000 feet. Loan behold, attached to the cable were critters,
因为越往下，活体组织承受的水压就越大，环境也越来越黑，在人们看来这再合乎情理不过了——你知道的，这就是我们的天性。人类中心主义真是太严重了：如果人类无法在那种地方生存，那其他东西大概也都活不了。但这些以人类为中心的怀疑论者很快就会被证明是错误的。各大洲即将通过电报电缆串联起来。从1858年开始，世界各国通过极长的电缆连接在了一起。信息将通过铺设在海底的电缆跨越巨大的距离。1860年，当人们为了维修而将一条地中海电缆从大约6000英尺（约1829米）深处拉上来时，奇迹发生了，附着在电缆上的竟然是生物，
mostly dead critters, but critters that were once alive. This discovery was much talked about in the press. There was life in the depths of the ocean and everyone wanted to know more about it. In 1872, the British Royal Navy sent a modified worship called the HMS Challenger out on one of the first scientific expeditions. It was this big, beautiful ship with sails. It looked like the kind of ship people hang paintings of, and old rustic pubs, or get tattooed on their bicep.
多半是已经死去的生物，但它们确实曾经是有生命的生物。这一发现引发了媒体的广泛报道。海洋深处确实存在生命，每个人都想了解更多。1872年，英国皇家海军派遣了一艘名为“挑战者”号的改装战舰，展开了最早的科学考察之旅之一。这是一艘巨大而美丽的帆船，挂着风帆。它看起来就像人们会挂在老式乡村酒吧里、或者纹在二头肌上的那种画作里的船。
The scientists and sailors spent four years on this ship, studying the Earth's oceans, trying especially to understand the deepest depths. And they did things like put down nets very deep into the water and go along hoping that the nets would catch something that was down there. But just like our bodies can't survive the pressure at great depths, fish that live at the bottom of the ocean aren't made to live at the top. So as they come up, they basically crystallize and fracture. So every cell explodes, rather than the whole animal, every cell explodes, and what you
科学家和水手们在这艘船上度过了四年时间，研究地球的海洋，尤其是试图弄清最深处的奥秘。他们会做一些诸如把网沉到极深的水中，然后拖着网前进，希望能网到海底生物的事情。但是，正如我们的身体无法承受深海的巨大压力一样，生活在海底的鱼类也不是为了适应浅海生存而造的。因此当它们被拉上来时，基本上会直接结晶并碎裂。不是整只动物破碎，而是每一个细胞都发生爆炸，每一个细胞都炸裂开来，最终呈现在你面前的是
have is a bag of goo. The scientists and sailors were pulling up giant nets of exploded fish goo. Still, they managed to gather a bunch of specimens that they saved in jars full of pickling alcohol as they sailed around the world. In the end, they traveled almost 70,000 nautical miles, dredging in pickling. It was hard work. But it was really an arduous trip because they started out with how many sailors, Jim? They started with with how many sailors, Jim. They started with 214 and ended with 144.
一袋黏糊糊的东西。科学家和水手们拉上来的，是一大网炸裂开来的鱼肉浆糊。尽管如此，他们在环球航行的过程中，还是设法收集了一大批标本，并把它们保存在装满防腐酒精的罐子里。最后，他们航行了将近70000海里，一路疏浚，一路浸泡。这是一项艰苦的工作。但这确实是一次极其艰辛的旅程，因为他们出发时有多少名水手，吉姆？他们出发时到底有多少名水手，吉姆。他们出发时有214人，结束时只剩下144人。
Two men went insane, two drowned, one committed suicide and several deserted. But the Challenger expedition did catalog around 4,000 new species and took depth measurements at hundreds of locations all over the ocean using a weighted string. On March 23rd, 1875, at station number 225, located in the southwest Pacific Ocean between Guam and Palau, the Ledzman cast their weighted string over the side of the ship, and it just kept dropping and dropping and dropping. A thousand feet, 10 thousand feet. Twenty thousand. Thirty thousand.
有两个人精神失常，两人溺水身亡，一人自杀，还有几人逃跑了。“挑战者”号考察队确实编录了大约4000个新物种，并利用带重物的绳索在海洋各处的数百个地点测量了深度。1875年3月23日，在位于关岛和帕劳之间的西南太平洋的第225号站点，水手们将系着重物的绳索抛入船舷外，而绳索却一直在下沉、下沉、下沉。一千英尺，一万英尺。两万。三万。
Right, we're gonna run out of strength! They had dropped their weight into the Mariana Trench and discovered what is still the deepest known place on the ocean floor. But despite the challenges many accomplishments, still, no one had actually been very deep in the ocean, been among the living creatures to see them alive in their natural habitats. There were various attempts at diving suits over the years. To picture the aesthetic range of these suits, start with
好吧，我们的绳子快用完了！他们把重物投进了马里亚纳海沟，发现了迄今为止已知海洋最深处。然而，尽管面临重重挑战并取得了诸多成就，依然没有人真正深入过海洋深处，没有亲眼在自然栖息地中观察过那些活生生的生物。多年来人们尝试过各种潜水服。要想想象这些潜水服的审美跨度，你可以从
Guy and a barrel with armholes and get to giant ridiculous Space Man robot suit. If you look back at these old suits, if you've seen the Lovie forbidden planet, you've seen these suits. Robbie the robot looks exactly like one of these suits. The Michelin Man looks a lot like these suits. They were incredibly heavy and cumbersome. You couldn't swim in them.
一个带有胳膊洞的木桶开始，一直想到那些巨大得荒唐的太空人机器人宇航服。如果你回看这些老式潜水服，如果你看过电影《禁忌星球》（Forbidden Planet），你就见过这种潜水服。机器人罗比（Robbie the robot）看起来就和其中一套潜水服一模一样。米其林轮胎人也很像这些潜水服。它们重得不可思议，又极其笨重。你根本没法穿着它们游泳。
You had to get dragged up to the surface by a boat. And they all had tubes that stretched up to the surface for oxygen. and they all had tubes that stretched up to the surface for oxygen. Using one of these suits, the Navy had sent a man 563 feet under the surface of a freshwater lake. Windowless submarines had been as deep as 383 feet in the ocean, but as of the 1920s, no one had gone further than that. And then came a scientist named William Beebe. William Beebe was a respected ornithologist and an exceedingly charming character who got
你只能被船只拖拽回水面。而且它们的身上都连着通往水面以获取氧气的管子。而且它们的身上都连着通往水面以获取氧气的管子。海军曾穿着其中一套潜水服，将一名男子送到了淡水湖水面以下563英尺（约172米）的地方。无窗潜水艇在海洋中的下潜深度曾达到过383英尺（约117米），但截至20世纪20年代，没有人突破过这个深度。直到一个名叫威廉·毕比（William Beebe）的科学家出现。威廉·毕比是一位受人尊敬的鸟类学家，也是一个极具魅力的人物，他总是
around by bicycle and spent his time gazing into the skies and writing about birds. Titles of his books include The Bird, Its Form and Function,, two bird lovers in Mexico and a monograph of fessence. He really loved birds. And then in the 1920s, while working near the coast, William Beebe turned his attention to the ocean. He would look down in the water and just spend hours wondering what was down there. And so then he started trying to think and plan a way that could get him down there. But his baby platted ways to go deep, he couldn't seem to think outside the cylinder, which was the shape of pre-existing submarines.
骑着自行车四处奔波，把时间都花在凝望天空和撰写关于鸟类的文章上。他的著作包括《鸟类：其形态与功能》、《墨西哥的两位鸟类爱好者》以及《关于发声的专著》。他是真的很喜欢鸟。然后在20世纪20年代，在海岸附近工作期间，威廉·毕比将注意力转向了海洋。他会低头注视着水面，花上好几个小时琢磨下面到底有什么。于是他开始构思并筹划一种能让自己下潜到那里的方法。但是，当毕比策划深潜方案时，他似乎无法跳出圆柱体的思维定式——那是先前潜水器的形状。
By baby's time of submarines could go down about 200 feet. If you went down further, they collapsed. They were crushed, the pressure outside, flattened everything inside. The result is you had a metal pancake and a lot of blood. And then in 1928 a young engineer named Otis Barton got in touch with BB and told him that to go as deep as he wanted to go, a cylinder was never going to work, but design had to be in the shape of a sphere. Even though the ocean depth brings on more and more pressure, the deeper you go, that pressure, if you're in a sphere, is pressing equally on every square inch of the sphere. Otis Barton told BB he'd help him design and engineer this new submersible, as long as he was allowed to accompany BB on all of the trips the sphere made into the sea.
在毕比的时代，潜水艇的下潜极限大约是200英尺（约61米）。如果再往下潜，它们就会解体。它们会被压扁，外部的水压将内部的一切都压得粉碎。结果就是你会得到一张金属煎饼和一堆血迹。到了1928年，一位名叫奥蒂斯·巴顿（Otis Barton）的年轻工程师联系了毕比，告诉他要想潜到他想去的深度，圆柱体是绝对行不通的，设计必须呈球形。尽管随着下潜深度的增加，海洋深处的压力会越来越大，但如果你身处一个球体内，这种压力会均等地施加在球体的每一个平方英寸上。奥蒂斯·巴顿告诉毕比，他会协助设计和建造这个新型潜水器，条件是允许他在球体每一次下海时都陪伴毕比同行。
Which was a pretty crazy thing for Barton to want, considering what a tiny, uncomfortable submersible he was about to make. The final design was about four and a half feet in diameter, and there wasn't a bench or even a level floor inside the bathosphere. They sat on this horrible cold wet concave floor that kind of pushed them together and they weren't really great friends either. This fear was made of steel and had two windows of thick fused quartz which provided an extremely clear view into the water. It also had a small
考虑到巴顿即将制造的潜水器是多么狭小逼仄、令人极不舒服，他提出这个要求可以说是相当疯狂了。最终的设计直径约为四英尺半（约1.37米），球形舱内部甚至没有长凳，也没有平坦的地板。他们只能坐在那个糟糕、冰冷、潮湿且向下凹陷的地板上，彼此挤在一起，而且他们其实也不是什么好朋友。这个球体由钢制成，带有两扇由厚熔融石英制成的窗户，这为水下提供了极其清晰的视野。它还有一个供人进出的
hatch to enter through. They called it the Bathosphere, Bathus being the Greek word for deep. William Beebe set up a sign station on non-such island in Bermuda, and they began doing dives in the Bathosphere. The submersible couldn't move on its own, so it had to be lowered on a cable off of a boat, and then kind of dragged around. In retrospect, the whole thing seems extremely low-tech. Well, it was 1930, and their high-tech is now our very, very low-tech.
小舱口。他们称之为“深海球形舱”（Bathosphere），其中“Bathus”是希腊语中“深”的意思。威廉·毕比在百慕大群岛的楠西奇岛（Non-such Island）建立了一个观测站，并开始使用深海球形舱进行下潜。这个潜水器无法自主移动，因此必须用船上的缆绳将其吊起放下，然后一路拖着走。现在回想起来，整个事情显得极其低技术含量。好吧，那是1930年，他们的高科技现在看来就是我们极其极其低的技术。
Inside the sphere were some canisters of oxygen and some trace of chemicals that soaked up the CO2 they were breathing out. It was cramped and humid in there. Condensation pooled on the floor, and Otis Barton was often seasick. They circulated the air with fans. Pomely fans, yes. Pomely fans back and forth. And that was the height of comfort.
球体内装有一些氧气罐和一些能够吸收他们呼出的二氧化碳的微量化学物质。里面空间逼仄，闷热潮湿。地板上积满了冷凝水，奥蒂斯·巴顿经常晕船。他们用风扇使空气流通。手摇扇，是的。来回摇动的手摇扇。那就是舒适度的极限了。
They were literally just fanning themselves with palm trees. Yep. It wasn't comfortable, but the sphere did completely shield them from the outside pressure. They didn't have to worry about the bends or decompression sickness that divers can experience when ascending too quickly. The thing that really scared them was the idea of a leak. Because if there were even a pinhole leak at those deep pressures, a jet of water would come in at such a high rate of pressure and speed that it would just be like being shot with a bullet.
他们真的只是拿着棕榈叶给自己扇风。没错。这并不舒服，但这个球体确实完全屏蔽了外部的水压。他们不必担心潜水员在上升过快时可能经历的潜水减压病。真正让他们感到害怕的是漏水的可能性。因为如果在如此深的高压环境下哪怕出现一个针孔大小的漏水点，一股水流也会以极高的压力和速度射进来，那种感觉就像是被一颗子弹击中一样。
If the two men could make it safely into the ocean steps, they would be able to see out into the dark ocean using a spotlight. The vessel also had a telephone that they could use to talk to the people in the boat above them. Their first dive on May 27, 1930, was just 45 feet down. But over time, BB and Barton started doing deeper and deeper dives in the bathosphere. When they sealed them in, it was incredibly noisy,
如果这两个人能够安全进入海洋深处，他们就能通过探照灯向外窥视黑暗的海洋。这个容器还配备了一部电话，他们可以用它与上方船上的人通话。他们在1930年5月27日的第一次下潜仅仅下到了45英尺（约14米）的深度。但随着时间的推移，毕比和巴顿开始在球形舱里进行越来越深的下潜。当他们被密封在里面时，噪音大得惊人，
because they had to hammer those big steel bolts in and that just drove BB crazy. Then you went to the surface and it was sloshing around and then it just got very very quiet. And you'd hear the sound of the oxygen coming in maybe very quiet, wish. the oxygen coming in maybe very quiet, wish. And then you hear the voice of Gloria who is on the other end of the telephone talking to BB. Gloria, to the back of the sphere. You're now at 285 feet over. The Lysotania is resting at this level.
因为他们必须把那些大型钢栓敲进去，这简直把毕比逼疯了。然后你浮到水面，到处都是水浪拍打的声音，接着一切就变得非常非常安静。然后你可能会听到氧气注入的声音，非常安静的嘶嘶声。氧气注入的声音，非常安静的嘶嘶声。接着你会听到电话另一端格洛里亚（Gloria）和毕比对话的声音。格洛里亚，致球体后方。你们现在位于285英尺（约87米）深处，完毕。“卢西塔尼亚号”正静静地躺在这个深度。
525 feet. The deepest point that a live human has ever reached. You're now at 600 feet. The only dead men have sunk below this. 1,426 feet. We are still alive in one quarter of a mile down. As they descended deeper, baby became obsessed with the changing light and color inside the bathosphere. In his memoir, a half mile down, he dedicates pages upon pages to this subject. The blueness of the blue, both outside and inside our sphere, seemed to mass materially through the eye, to our very beams
525英尺（约160米）。活人到达过的最深点。你们现在到了600英尺（约183米）。只有死人才会沉到这个深度以下。1426英尺（约435米）。我们在四分之一英里（约402米）深的海底依然活着。随着不断下潜，毕比开始对深海球形舱内不断变化的光线和色彩着迷。在他的回忆录《下潜半英里》中，他用了整页又整页的篇幅来描写这个主题。无论是球体外部还是内部，蓝色的那种蔚蓝感似乎切实地穿透了眼睛，直击我们的心扉，
an indefinable translucent blue, quite unlike anything I've ever seen in the upper world. As the bathosphere is some lower and lower, the light is attenuated more and more and more. Until finally they would have been floating in complete darkness, though bebe and Barton both swore there was somehow still an aura of blueness to the blackness. It's as if the blue had seeped so thoroughly into their eyeballs
呈现出一种无法言喻的半透明蓝，与我在上层世界见过的任何东西都截然不同。随着深海球形舱越降越低，光线被越来越强烈地削弱。直到最后，他们仿佛漂浮在绝对的黑暗中，尽管毕比和巴顿都发誓，在那种黑暗中，某种蓝色的光晕不知为何依然存在。就好像蓝色已经如此彻底地渗入了他们的眼球，
that they still saw it, even in the dark. And BB comments on this and many people have been down, comment on this. When he wasn't having his mind blown by the varying shades of blue, BB was tripping out on the fish. After the sunlight disappeared, the only fish they'd be able to see without their spotlight were the ones that provided their own light. That is, fish with bioluminescence, so they spent a lot of time turning the spotlight on and on and off. running the spotlight on and off and on and off. 1900 feet, bathesides is pentagrass, the five line consolation fish. A fish almost round with long water behind.
以至于即使在黑暗中他们依然能看到它。毕比对此做出了评论，许多下潜过的人也对此发表了评论。当他的大脑没有被各种深浅不一的蓝色所震撼时，毕比正被各种鱼类迷得神魂颠倒。阳光消失后，除了他们自己的探照灯外，他们能看到的唯一的鱼就是那些能够自带光源的鱼。也就是说，拥有生物发光的鱼，所以他们花了很多时间把探照灯打开、关上、再打开。不断地把探照灯打开、关上、打开、关上。1900英尺（约579米），深海五线鱼，一种几乎呈圆形、身后拖着长长尾巴的鱼。
The ocean was teeming with strange looking creatures at all depths. Beebe would describe these creatures in great detail over the telephone line that went up to the boat above. Along the sides of the body were five unbelievably beautiful lines of light. One equatorial with two curved ones above and two below. Each line was composed of a series of them. And then Elsa Bostelman, who was an amazing artist, was there on board as well, and she would make sketches. And then when Baby finally came up, he would look them over and say, yes, that's right, and she would make sketches. And then when Beebe finally came up, he would look them over and say, yes, that's right. No, that's wrong.
海洋里到处都是在各个深度游弋的奇形怪状的生物。毕比通过通往上方船只的电话线，极其详细地描述了这些生物。身体两侧排列着五条美得令人难以置信的光带。一条在赤道面上，上方两条呈弧形，下方两条也是。每条线都由一串发光器组成。当时，埃尔莎·博斯特尔曼（Elsa Bostelman）这位了不起的艺术家也在船上，她会进行素描。等毕比终于上来后，他会仔细查看并说：“没错，就是这样”，然后她会进行素描。等毕比终于上来后，他会仔细查看并说：“没错，就是这样。不对，画错了。
Straighten it all out. Everyone was surrounded by a semi-circle, a very small but intensely purple photo-force. Many of Baselman's sketches were published in National Geographic, and the creatures they portrayed were so strange, so otherworldly that readers couldn't believe they were real. A lot of people actually accuse BB of making stuff up.
全部纠正过来。”每个人都被一个半圆所环绕，那是一个非常小但却异常紫红色的光器。博斯特尔曼的许多草图发表在《国家地理》杂志上，它们所描绘的生物是如此奇异、如此超脱世俗，以至于读者根本不敢相信它们是真的。许多人甚至指责毕比凭空捏造。
And that hurt BB. Poor BB. But almost everything that he described that so many people thought could not possibly exist has since been discovered. Only two or three still haven't been found. Over the course of four years, BB and Barton made dozens of dives and catalog several new species of fish. They made it to 3,028 feet deep, six times deeper than anyone had ever been. On one of his final dives in the bathosphere, William BB saw something he'd never seen before.
这让毕比很受伤。可怜的毕比。但几乎他所描述的、被许多人认为绝不可能存在的一切后来都被发现了。只有两三种至今尚未被找到。在四年的时间里，毕比和巴顿进行了数十次下潜，并编录了好几种新的鱼类。他们下潜到了3028英尺（约923米）的深度，这是人类有史以来达到过最深记录的六倍。在深海球形舱的最后几次下潜中，威廉·毕比看到了一件他从未见过的事物。
He saw this enormous seasnake on the bottom of the ocean. It was long and black, the longest creature he'd ever seen. And tracked it for a while before he realized that it was the Atlantic cable. It was one of the transatlantic telegraph wires that had gotten the whole world interested in understanding the bottom of the ocean. By 1934, the Bathosphere Project had lost funding and BB was on to other adventures. He really felt that he'd done everything he could do with the bathosphere. The main problem being it wasn't self-propelled, that you just hung there wherever, you know, you happened to drop and you couldn't, for instance, move it to follow an interesting fish or turn it around at will.
他看到海底有一条巨大的海蛇又长又黑，是他见过的最长的生物。他追踪了它一会儿，才意识到那是大西洋电缆。那是最早让全世界对了解海底产生兴趣的跨大西洋电报电缆之一。到1934年，“深海球形舱”项目失去了资金支持，毕比也转向了其他的冒险。他真的觉得自己已经用深海球形舱完成了所有能做的事。主要问题在于它无法自主推进，你只能悬挂在无论你碰巧被放下去的哪个地方，比方说，你无法移动它去追踪一条有趣的鱼，也无法随心所欲地将它掉头。
Eventually, people would figure out how to make a submersible that could move on its own. Two of these subs, the Trieste in 1966 and the Deep Sea Challenger in 2012, actually made it all the way to the bottom of the Mariana Trench. The bathosphere is now on display in the New York Aquarium at Coney Island. You can peer inside of it and marvel at the idea that two men once sat squeezed together on its concave steel floor, fanning themselves with palm fronds, in awe of the shifting shades of blue, the creatures beneath the sea, and their place in all of it. I shall never experience such a feeling of complete isolation from the surface of planet
最终，人们将弄清楚如何制造一种能够自主移动的潜水器。其中两艘潜水器——1966年的“的里雅斯特”号（Trieste）和2012年的“深海挑战者”号（Deep Sea Challenger）——真的成功抵达了马里亚纳海沟的最底部。深海球形舱现在正陈列在科尼岛（Coney Island）的纽约水族馆（New York Aquarium）里。你可以透过它向内窥视，并为这样一个想法感到惊叹：两个男人曾经紧紧挤在一起，坐在它向下凹陷的钢制地板上，用棕榈叶给自己扇风，惊叹于变幻莫测的蓝色色调、海面下的生物，以及他们在这一切中所处的位置。我将永远不会体验到那种与来自行星表面的完全隔绝感，
Earth, as when I first dangled in a hollow pea on a swaying cobweb, a quarter of a mile below the The Bathosphere is just one chapter in William BB's life. Carol Gould wrote a book about the rest of it, it's called The Remarkable Life of William BB. Special thanks to Ron Allem who designed the deep sea challenger and Captain Don Walsh Gold wrote a book about the rest of it, it's called The Remarkable Life of William Beebe. Special thanks to Ron Allem who designed the deep sea challenger and Captain Don Walsh who descended into the Mariana Trench on the Trieste. They both spent time talking to us about this story. Thank you to the 99 PI players, Avery, Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Pat Masidi Miller for doing the sound design this week.
就像我第一次悬挂在一个在摇曳的蜘蛛网上的空心豌豆里，身处距离水面四分之一英里（约402米）的海底深处……深海球形舱只是威廉·毕比人生中的一个章节。卡罗尔·古尔德写了一本关于他其余人生的书，书名叫《威廉·毕比的卓越人生》（The Remarkable Life of William Beebe）。特别感谢设计了“深海挑战者”号的罗恩·阿勒姆（Ron Allum），以及乘坐“的里雅斯特”号潜入马里亚纳海沟的唐·沃尔什（Don Walsh）船长。古尔德写了一本关于他其余人生的书，书名叫《威廉·毕比的卓越人生》。特别感谢设计了“深海挑战者”号的罗恩·阿勒姆，以及乘坐“的里雅斯特”号潜入马里亚纳海沟的唐·沃尔什船长。他们两人都花时间与我们谈论了这个故事。感谢99%隐形栏目的各位成员：阿弗里、特鲁弗曼，以及我——罗曼·马斯。特别感谢帕特·马西迪·米勒（Pat Masidi Miller）负责本周的音频设计。
If you want to hear his work on a weekend, week out basis, I suggest you subscribe to the Fantastic Radio Program, Snap Judgment. The newest member of 99% of its bowl is Kurt Colstad. He's our digital director, so please say hi to him. But we are still looking for a reporter, producer to join us in Oakland so get your applications in. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arksign, an architecture and interiors firm, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. One of our favorite bands for scoring our stories is called Lelatone. I'm talking over their music right now.
如果你想每周都听到他的作品，我建议你订阅精彩的广播节目《突发审判》（Snap Judgment）。99%栏目的最新成员是库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstad）。他是我们的数字总监，所以请向他打个招呼吧。但我们仍在寻找记者兼制作人加入我们在奥克兰的团队，所以请把你们的申请投递过来吧。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW广播电台的一个项目，制作办公室位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的建筑与室内设计公司Arksign。我们为故事配乐时最喜欢的乐队之一叫Lelatone。我现在正伴着他们的音乐说话。
They have something like 20 albums or EPs on Bandcamp. You should get at least one of them, and I recommend all of them. Go to Lelatone.bandcamp.com. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify, and you can listen to every single episode of 99% Thank you. Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们在Bandcamp上有大约20张专辑或EP。你应该入手至少一张，我推荐全部买下。请访问Lelatone.bandcamp.com。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并给它点赞。我们都在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上有账号，你可以收听99%的每一集节目。谢谢。电台塔皮奥。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。